Conor McGregor came with proper 12. boom
it was a 600 million dollar deal The
Rock had taramana tequila which is now
worth like 4 billion Kylie made the
front of Forbes as a billionaire and she
was 20. Mr Beast he will be a sense of
billionaire right now the entire economy
has shifted the last century was a
century about the power and when I say
power I mean like energy the wealthiest
individuals of the last century were
built on oil the biggest companies were
all energy companies fast forward today
four out of the top five biggest
companies in the world are not built on
the old oil but the new oil and the oil
of today is attention rise in teens on
tick tocks the thing that is being
pumped and drilled every day is the
attention of the masses you have 24
hours a day that your ears are open you
have 24 hours a day that your eyes are
open and so the idea is how can we
capture as many of those hours from as
many people as possible and the war for
our minds for me the stuff is all about
like helping people connect the total of
attention that exists is every human's
eyes and ears collectively 24 hours a
day that is the pie and they're fighting
for it people who are creating the
platforms that other companies can come
and drill they're basically the digital
landscape they envelope the world
they're literally buying up the real
estate of the collective attention that
exists the oil tycoons had to go and buy
a state negotiate haggle with the farmer
to get us things the new world today
they don't need to haggle with anyone
they just take it scarce resources are
the things that are the most valuable
and so oil was the scarce resource and
now attention is the scarce resource and
so that's why attention is the new oil a
friend of mine Ryan Fisher just showed
me a clip on his phone of a podcast that
I did with him this is when I wasn't
really actually I didn't do any podcast
I was that wasn't doing any speaking
stuff like all I was doing was building
gym launcher Prestige Labs I was like
screw content just run ads I don't want
to be known I want to be rich and
unknown it's funny because he was like
and now you're not doing that I was very
against it and then what happened Kylie
made the front of Forbes as a
billionaire and she was 20. and at the
time I was 27 and I think I had taken
home 17 million in income the year
before I was on Pace to do like 13 to 15
that next year in terms of take home and
I thought like I was hot [ __ ] and then
this girl is seven years younger than me
[ __ ] crushes me in net worth and I
was like Wow and so it was just this
huge belief shift for me where I was
like what am I doing wrong my ego felt
hurt so I started protecting myself and
I was like oh no Kris Jenner's her mom
she's an absolute gangster she was born
into this royalty it's not that she did
it it was someone else and blah blah ego
protected I feel okay now and then Huda
Beauty sold a percentage of her thing
for 600 million at the time it's worth
over a billion today Conor McGregor came
out with proper 12 and 12 months later
boom it was a 600 million dollar deal
robot 12 and then the rock had taramana
tequila which is now worth like four
billion just kept seeing this again and
again and again to the point where I was
like I I believe something that's not
true and so I talk about how skills
beliefs character traits are the three
things that hold back entrepreneurs and
this one for me was something that I
believed about the world and I was
functioning as though and it was not I
was trying to find those things because
they construct our reality and we make
our decisions based on the things that
we believe to be true and so I basically
was walking through a reality that was
not real I then read a book mine of all
rubikov which is his Almanac which is
really good really quick read and you
talked about the four types of Leverage
in the book Leverage is the difference
between what you put in and what you get
out the people who make the most money
are the ones who have the most leverage
because everybody's the same amount of
time it's just who gets the most back
for their time and compounding is that
now that you've made that trade with
your Leverage is it going to compound
unto itself and get you even more back
because compounding is a form of
Leverage and you've got labor you get
other people to do stuff for you which
means you get more of your time back and
you get output above that you've got
Capital so people give you money you
invest the money that other people give
you and you get leveraged by extension
the last two levels are code so you got
software and media so if you think about
this you make a piece of code and then
10 million people can use it that's
leverage you put one-time investment you
get infinite on the other side with
media it's the same way if I take
however much time it takes me to make
this video one person a million people a
hundred million people can see this
video which is what gives it leverage
when I saw that that was what made
everything click for me as to why these
people were getting these crazy crazy
numbers when they had like I had heard
Kylie had a team of seven and she was
doing 200 million a year I was like team
of seven and was because she had a
compounding leverage vehicle built
within her business and that was when I
looked at my own businesses at the time
and realized I had nothing that
compounded nothing I almost became
dissatisfied with the business that I
had because I realized that whatever I
wanted to do next I wanted to have a
compounding vehicle something that
multiplies unto itself over and over
again so Warren Buffett could build
Berkshire Hathaway because the money
itself compounds and compounds and
compounds and on a long enough time
Horizon when you keep rolling the
snowball after you do that for 40 50
years you have a big [ __ ] snowball
you have to unlock one of those four
types of Leverage and so when I looked
at that pyramid I was like well I
understand the leverage of Labor so I've
got that I'm now in a position where I
have Capital that I can deploy now I
don't have other people's Capital
because that's not what I want to do
with my life right now but when I looked
at software and media I was like given
my skills Etc I could be better at the
media side than I could at the code side
but I still wasn't there yet I looked at
these people that are Ultra famous and I
was like huh well I'd still rather be
anonymous because they've got all these
stalkers and Weirdos hey good morning
when you get exposed to 10 million
people if you figure one percent of
people are crazy you got a hundred
thousand weirdos anyways I go to have
dinner with a friend of mine uh Dean
graciosi who's he gets like weirdos that
come to his house and all that kind of
stuff and I was like how do you deal
with this I was like why do you think
this like how is this worth it you just
had me down he was like
dude if if a couple weird letters
you know every day or every week is the
price I have to pay for the impact I
want to have he's like I pay that price
any day of the week and twice on Sunday
and there was just like this pause when
he said it between when he said it and
he looked at me and I just felt like it
hit me because I was like God I'm being
such a pansy I want to make real
business education available to everyone
if I say that that's what I actually
want to do then I need to match my
actions to that otherwise they're just
empty words I hate doing something that
I don't get credit for later and so the
idea of making a short that is going to
float today and then disappear into the
ether tomorrow right or make a post on
Instagram that's going to be gone in a
week like no one's ever going to see it
again to me taking the scarce resources
of my time and then having it vanish I
couldn't make that work for me it was a
huge belief that I realized the content
is not the output is the input
the output is the audience and the
audience is what compounds the audience
is what sticks you're Gathering the
scarce resource and the audience is the
thing that pumps attention over and over
again you've got Mr Beast I think he
opened up a restaurant in a local area
and had 10 000 people show up at a local
restaurant I don't think people realize
that he's 24 and media compounds I will
make a prediction that he will be a
sense of billionaire not just a
billionaire but a sense a billionaire
and so becoming a master of media is a
huge way of creating leverage because if
Kylie can just point or Mr Beast can
just point and then you have a hundred
million people who buy anything
you have a billion dollar plus company
but once that shifted in me I'd stop
seeing it as a waste because I thought
if I got one more person who's gonna see
this short or see this long or see this
post or see this tweet or see this
whatever that was the point the reason
Huda The Rock Conor McGregor or Kylie
were able to translate their attention
into money one they spent a long time
building it right and amassing that
attention because they knew that the
moment they did decide to monetize it it
was right there think about how long The
Rock has been building the brand of the
rock before he signed his deal with
Under Armor before he made termana
before he made zoa 20 years he'd been
building this brand people piss and moan
about the fact that you know they posted
content for four weeks and they're not
famous yet one is they waited a really
really long time and they didn't ask
they just they gave they give to their
particular audience the longer you can
wait the bigger the ass can be at the
end the longer the runway the bigger the
plane that can take off from it the next
thing is that the thing they chose to
monetize from was on brand this is
something that Their audience already
dug the Rye signing the deal with Under
Armor makes complete sense because
Fitness is a core part of his brand it's
about drive it's about power we stay
hungry we devour like all of that is
something that Under Armor wanted to tap
into to associate their brand with the
biggest brands that exist come from the
endorsements of celebrities we can't be
Kim Kardashian a girl can't be Kim so
Kim is the ultimate status then Dolce
Gabbana signs Kim and says wear our [ __ ]
people then see the status that Kim has
and Associate it with Dolce Gabbana and
then little lady who's got money and
doesn't have status trades her money for
the bag that she can associate with Kim
to get the status that's the game let's
look at LeBron and Nike they wanted to
sign him because they figure he is going
to be iconic he is Iconic right and they
wanted to associate Nike Victory with
somebody who's Victorious because a
brand can't be victorious in and of
itself it's not a person and so they got
to find the people who embody the spirit
and the values of their brand they make
the endorsement people make the
association in their mind and then they
buy the brand to get the the association
of the thing they could never do but
always aspire to the people who are the
most famous you look at Rogan right he's
got UFC he's also a really amazing
comedian and loves the comedy community
Fitness and biohacking and supplements
and all and like brain stuff he loves
all that stuff aliens and UFOs and these
are all totally different but the more
Dimensions that someone can go deep on
the more they'll get an audience from
Comedy and then they'll cross-pollinate
them with fighting it's this total
pollination which ultimately compounds
the audience even faster and so these
Mega stars go deep on many things and
capture bigger and bigger audiences that
Compound on themselves and they wait
because they stay loyal to their brand
and then they appeal to a segment of
Their audience or they try to cut across
the one that appeals to the most of them
it took me way too long to realize that
the game had changed fundamentally if
the Rockefellers were built on oil the
new generation of people are going to be
built on attention media will only
become more expensive over time
advertising becomes more expensive
content creation becomes more expensive
it becomes increasingly fragmented so it
costs more to do it across different
platform the audience becomes more
valuable the cost of getting the
audience becomes more valuable which
means the best time to start is now the
people who will become the new sense of
billionaires Etc is going to be people
who can do three things they will be
able to capture they have to be able to
hold they have to be able to multiply
attention